hi I'm Evan Carmichael and in today's
video I wanted to answer questions from
what I read there sanchita who is a
salesperson for a london-based
technology company and is having a hard
time doing cold calling and getting
through to the decision maker either
always gets the voicemail or gets the
gatekeeper receptionist and is wondering
what my advice would be so to be honest
I don't have a lot of success or
experience with cold calling I've always
found that to be a successful
entrepreneur you need to figure out what
you're really good at and what you're
not so good at and I found out pretty
early on that cold Colin was not one of
my strengths but to help you out I
thought I would share some of my
experience and how I've successfully
done sales and hopefully you can learn
from that so I've always found that I
have a much greater chance of being able
to sell somebody when they already know
a little bit about me and they're
calling me or emailing me and finding a
way to contact me about what I have to
offer and I've done that through three
separate ways and all of them are free
or pretty low cost which is magic words
for an entrepreneur the first is through
SEO or search engine optimization so
that's where you great content on your
website that is tailored towards your
target audience they type in keywords
into a search engine and they come up
and find your site and I always found
this a great way to be able to get new
prospects find out about my website and
calling me it's great because they have
a specific problem they're doing
research they're trying to find a
solution your website comes up and so
they're they're gonna contact you and
there they have a good chance of one
good buy from you where I kind of the
full calling it's really hit or miss and
it's a big numbers game so I'd rather
have my website do the selling for me so
you just have to figure out what are the
keywords that need to rank for and how
can you create useful content around
that that
driving in traffic for you if you have
questions a lot a whole new video just
on that series the second way that I
found really useful to bring in new
customers is to form partnerships so
find out who else your target customers
are buying from and see if there's a way
you can pair up with them
hopefully they're not your competition
but people who have maybe complementary
products or services to what you offer
and you should sprit easy to get in
touch with partners and see if is a way
to form some kind of relationship so you
want to make it win-win where you're
hopefully talking about them when
they're talking about you and it could
be a great way to be able to get in
touch with new potential prospects and
when they're introduced to you through a
trusted partner again it's a lot easier
to make that sale compared to just
calling somebody that you don't know the
last way that I've had a lot of success
with in terms of generating sales is to
be an expert with the media so the media
are always looking for experts to talk
about industry trends and comment on
stories that are happening and when I
first got started I would create a new
press release every week I made my own
list of reporters who I wanted to target
and would send them information every
week to show that I'm an expert on
entrepreneurship and you want to give
them really value I story ideas not just
a press release about how great you are
but talking about something that's
happening a trend and give your own
insights to it I also more recently use
a service called PR leads that reporters
submit their stories to and you can
become an expert and offer your advice
and gotten into New York Times and
Forbes and Wall Street Journal and when
people see that the read those
publications they then find your website
or find your phone number and get in
touch with you and are more
- wanna buy fuel they're curious to want
more information so I I've had good
success with those tactics if I'm doing
SEO or if I'm doing partnerships or if
I'm doing media I haven't had a lot of
like the cold falling : can work just
hasn't been really successful for me so
I encourage you to try to find out what
your strengths and weaknesses are and
adopt your strategies around that it'll
be a lot more successful I hope you
enjoyed the video of that answered some
of your questions if you like the video
please give it a thumbs up
I'd also love to hear thoughts and
feedback if you want to leave a comment
below the video and stay tuned for next
episode
you